[Musique]
les mots du premier ministre du québec
sont durs les 10 % de non vaccinées dans
la province sont des fardeaux ils
doivent assumer et payer tous les
adultes au québec qui accepteront pas
dans les prochaines semaines d'aller au
moins chercher une première dose ben
auront une facture à payer parce que il
ya des conséquences sur notre réseau de
la santé donne fifty cent of the pop
life in d'origine bulbilles insect au
micro et de next 6-2 et weeks et si
cette propagation fulgurante du varions
omicron annoncé par l'om et pourrait
enfin être une bonne nouvelle ce
scénario optimiste ce matin envisagée
par les scientifiques est les
différentes autorités sanitaires tout
son visage une augmentation de
l'immunité naturelle dans la population
avec la propagation du variant omikron
en attendant nouveau record de carrière
en france près de 370 mille tests
qu'ovide à répétition pour les enfants
file d'attenté interminable
exaspération des parents et fatigue des
enseignants le protocole sanitaire à
l'école pousse les professeurs à la
grève demain un ras-le-bol contre les
décisions du gouvernement alors ici
cette mère de famille s'organise grâce à
son activité et au télétravail de son
mari arthur 9 ans pourra rester à la
maison avec déjà un programme en tête
que l'on penserait c'est à dire que la
vaccination a favorisé la
l'augmentation du nombre de covin cette
erreur là a été fatale à mon mari je ne
vous en veux d'avoir été crédule inde
avoir été naïf j'en veux bien évidemment
à didier rahout t il son ego démesuré je
crains la violence en général je crains
les violences quand elle n'est pas
maîtrisée je crains la haine je crains
aussi c'est cette espèce de crescendo
permanent parce que on va de plus en
plus loin candidat emmanuel macron qui
vient à nice avec les moyens de l'état
avec les moyens du contribuable donc en
grand équipage comme on dit en jet de
présidente et c'est pour annoncer un
programme présidentiel à horizon 2030
alors ça c'est scandaleux ce week-end
ali a retraité de 67 ans déambule dans
le centre ville de noisy le sec
lorsqu'il croise des jeunes en voiture
m'a dit est ce que je vais t'en donne
une mais sorti mon paquet oui sortir une
cigarette il m'a pris la main elle m'a
dit maintenant tu vas courir aucun
risque ses responsables honnêtement moi
personnellement regardant cette vidéo
mais je n'étais pas vous pouvez nous
assurer qu'il est en prison mais moi je
suis pas ministre de la santé je suis
pas juge et je suis pas procureur de la
république je respecte la séparation des
pouvoirs je peux vous assurer qu'ils ont
été interpellés on à gérald darmanin qui
a franchi toutes les bornes que la
mauvaise foi il était social nicolas
sarkozy l'accusent nicolas sarkozy dont
on fait une mauvaise politique en sur m
6 a été d'avoir supprimé des effectifs
ces personnes répondront leurs actes
répondent de leurs actes en ce moment
devant des enquêteurs est manifestement
elle sans pouvoir qualifier il a voulu
le tuer cette personne manifestement
j'ai vu que dans une émission il a
demandé à valérie pécresse de lui donner
les parrainages en disant quelque chose
de très clair si je n'ai pas les
parrainages alors c'est marine le pen
qui sera au second tour et ce ne sera
pas valérie pécresse donc je me pose la
question ça pourquoi cette candidature
il est temps qu'un président se dresse
devant le ministère des finances et lui
donne l'ordre d'arrêter immédiatement
d'emmerder les premières sens je veux
être ce président je veux être cet homme
qui fait passer les commerçants des
villages avant bercy et le marchand de
vêtements pour enfants du bout de la rue
avant le parlement européen c'est ce
qu'il a dit il dit si je n'ai pas mes
parrainages alors marine le pen sera au
second tour et ça ne sera pas vers les
pécresse donc il faut que la maîtresse
me donne les parrainages mais pardon ça
veut dire que voilà j'ai craché valérie
pécresse et son actionnaire majoritaire
donc